hallo herzlich willkommen in sallyis
Welt heute gibt's nach langer Zeit
endlich mal wieder ein nachgemacht
original trifft Sally und zwar trifft
die Sally heute auch Ikea cinnamon
[Musik]
BNS das werden wir heute zubereiten ich
stell die jetzt aber mal wieder ins
Gefrierfach denn das sind die großen
schönen leckeren kardamum zinchnecken
die es bei Ikea gibt die werden einfach
nur auf dem Blech gelegt und Backen
natürlich machen wir später den
Geschmackstest und probieren natürlich
beide
aber diese Zimtschnecken müssen ja
erstmal eigentlich nur gebacken werden
und bei mir muss jetzt erstmal noch der
hefeteag zubereitet werden also gibt's
hier einmal die Zutaten ich verwende
dafür einen Würfel hefeel 20 ml Wasser
80 g Zucker 220 g Milch die darf gerne
ein bisschen warm sein muss aber nicht
500 g Mehl da könnt ihr Weizen oder
Dinkel 630 benutzen einen telef Salz ein
Ei hier habe ich ein paar kardamum
Kapseln sag gleich was dazu und 80 g
weiche Butter also es ist so der
Hefeteig ist einfach in der Zubereitung
aber es gibt Dinge die ich euch jetzt
sagen muss weil ich in letzter Zeit oft
Hefeteig oder hefesachen gegessen habe
die nicht so lecker waren es liegt am
Salz ich sag's euch wie es ist das ist
perfekt also diese Salzmenge hier ist
perfekt für 500 g Mehl das ist ein
Teelöffel und ich habe diese Messlöffel
auch dafür entwickelt dass man immer
genügend Salz nimmt denn auch in
Süßspeisen ist es so wenn ihr zu wenig
Salz habt schmeckt das Ganze weniger süß
und wenn ihr gerade so einen süßen
Hefeteig habt und ihr habt echt zu wenig
Salz weil viele nehmen dann einfach so
ein bisschen eine Prise dann schmeckt
der Hefeteig nicht dann schmeckt
tatsächlich so als wäre zu wenig Zucker
drin oder es fehlt irgendwas aber
meistens fehlt dann kein Zucker sondern
es fehlt Salz und deswegen auf 500 g
Mehl immer einen Teelöffel hier diesen
Messlöffel voll Salz und dann ist es
perfekt dann vertraut mir ist ist dann
perfekt dann schmeckt's gut und das ist
das was in den Zutaten oder in dem
Rezept oft fehlt deswegen bin ich da
immer so penibel was so die Messlöffel
angeht weil ich habe so ein Viertel ein
halben ein ganzen ein Esslöffel und da
passt dann halt die Menge immer perfekt
da könnt ihr auch drauf vertrauen immer
so ein gestrichener Teelöffel okay so
viel
dazu gebe ich die Hefe das Wasser und
den Zucker einfach in die Rührschüssel
und verrühre die Zutaten schon mal ganz
kurz Hefe löst sich nämlich in Wasser
gut auf und Zucker komm dazu weil hierfe
Zucker sehr mag Fett und Salz kommen
erst am Ende dazu dann gebe ich jetzt
das Mehl dazu me
Ei
Milch und jetzt am Ende einfach die
Butter drauf und das Salz dazu einen
Teelöffel und während der Teig jetzt
hier knetet der darf 10 Minuten lang
kneten damit das schön geschmeidig ist
und vor allem wird Hefeteig immer besser
je länger ihr ein Knete es hat einfach
mit dem Mehl zu tun und dann klebt er
auch nicht mehr er hat eine super
Konsistenz er ist total elastisch also
lasst den wirklich ruhig se Minuten lang
knittenen gerne auch wenn ihr die
kennwut habt mit bisschen Hitze so 25
bis 30° und ich kann in der Zwischenzeit
hier schon mal die kardamum Kapseln
aufmachen ihr könnt kardamum natürlich
auch gemahlen kaufen hat aber kleine
Nachteile Vorteil ist bei gemahlenem
kardamum ihr müsst nicht mehr malen
Nachteil ist bei kardamum ist es so das
ist eine Kapsel und das sind hier diese
kardamum Samen drin und wenn ihr
gemahlenen kardamum kauft ist praktisch
die Kapsel mit zerkleinert und der
kardmum ist so ein
bisschen qualitativ schlechter weil wir
die Kapsel nicht möchten das heißt ich
mache hier die Kapsel gleich auf und
dann die kleinen katamom Samen einfach
zerkleinern dann haben wir den vollen
Geschmack
also macht euch das Leben einfach und
öffnet die Kapsel mit der
messerrückseite einfach mit Messer drauf
dann öffnet sich die Kapsel und jetzt
könnt ihr entweder ein merser oder einen
Mixer nehmen ich habe hier sogar einen
kleinen gewürzmixer eine kleine
Gewürzmühle an der kwood und das kann
ich jetzt hier oben zerkleinern und dann
zum Teig dazu geben und den Teig schön
fertig kneten falls ihr übrigens merkt
dass der Teig ein bisschen zu weich ist
gebt ihr noch ein Esslöffel Mehl dazu es
kommt halt auch immer drauf an weil man
ja mit Ei arbeitet und das Ei oft eine
unterschiedliche Größe hat kann es sein
dass man vielleicht so ein Esslöffel
mehr oder ein Esslöffel weniger
[Musik]
braucht das riecht gut das riecht
intensiv so sieht der Teig perfekt aus
schön weich aber wie ihr seht er klebt
nicht
und jetzt nehme ich den raus kann ihn
schön zu einer Kugel formen und dann
abgedeckt für eine Stunde aufgehen
lassen ihr könnt ihn aber auch ganz
gerne in der Kenwood aufgehen lassen die
hat ja die hitzefunktion dauert dann so
ungefähr eine dreiviertel Stunde oder
bei euch im Dampfbackofen ich habe beim
boschbackofen auch die gerstufe und dort
hat man sogar den Vorteil dass der
Backofen eine dampfstufe hat und durch
den Dampf der Teig eben nicht
austrocknet und da braucht nur
[Musik]
dre
der Hefeteig ist jetzt super aufgegangen
jetzt kann ich die Zimtfüllung
zubereiten dafür nehme ich 80 g weiche
Butter 80 g Zucker etwas Vanille Extrakt
und Zimt die Zutaten werden jetzt
einfach nur kurz verrührt ich weiß noch
früher habe ich so gemacht dass ich oft
die teigblatter mit Butter bestrichen
habe und dann Zimt und Zucker drauf
gestreut habe aber es geht natürlich
viel besser und ist viel gleichmäßiger
wenn ihr butter Zucker und Zimt einfach
verrührt dann habt ihr nicht so eine
dunkle Stelle mit Zimt sondern es
verteilt sich eben
perfekt ihr seht ich lerne auch dazu mit
den
Jahren W aber ich ler dazu
[Musik]
gerne bevor es jetzt an meine
zimschnecken geht backen wir jetzt
erstmal die IKEA zimschnecken würde ich
sagen die muss ich nämlich nur gefroren
aufs Blech legen zack zack
zack und im vorgehizen Ofen backen
ich zeige euch später auch ganz gerne
wie ihr eure zimschnecken vorbereiten
und einfrehen könnt denn ihr könnt euch
auch die eigenen zimschnecken auf Vorrat
machen falls ihr sagt ihr wollt jetzt
nicht das komplette Rezept heute backen
weil ihr z.B alleine wohnt aber trotzdem
immer gerne zimschnecken
habt ich spreche Anna jetzt an hinter
der
Kamera da kannst du Anna immer
Zimtschnecken machen einfrieren und wenn
dir wenn du Lust auf eine hast einfach
nur eine einzige Backen echt jetzt ein
den Ofen
anschmeißen natürlich direkt immer die
volle Menge machen auf jeden Fall Gott
sehen die gut aus aber mal gucken ob
meine noch schöner werden ich back die
[Musik]
mal dann rolle ich jetzt erstmal den
Hefeteig
[Musik]
aus ich hier auf meinem ausrollstab die
5 mm Abstandsringe damit könnt ihr den
Teig nämlich perfekt gleichmäßig
ausrollen ich muss ja
sagen bisher waren die besten Zimt
kardanum Schnecken die die janbn für
mich gebacken hat die waren mal richtig
gut bitte nimm dir einfach eine runter
genau neh wir auch eine runter Hef
Gebäck ist mein liebstes Gebäck kannst
du für Weg noch ein paar einpacken ja es
hat jetzt ungefähr das Maß 40 auf 40 cm
normalerweise muss ich sagen gerade bei
Nusszopf bei anderen Dingen die ich
ausrolle und bestreiche mache ich jetzt
bisschen dünner damit ich mehr Schichten
habe aber ich passe es jetzt optisch
tatsächlich den Ikea nussschnecken
zimschnecken an und will einfach eine
schöne dicke Teigschicht mit viel dicker
[Musik]
butterschicht und falls ihr Probleme
damit habt die Rolle nach dem Aufrollen
zu schneiden könnt ihr das auch so
machen dass ihr jetzt Streifen
zuschneidet und dann jede Zimtschnecke
für sich aufrollt dann zerquetscht es
später nicht so aber ich schneide es
gleich mit einem Faden deswegen Rolle
ich das ganze jetzt schön vorsichtig
auf ich habe davon geträumt ich habe ins
gefrifach geguckt habe die IKEA
Schnecken entdeckt und dann habe ich mir
gedacht Po Ikea Schnecken das W jetzt
auch mal was cooles und dann dachte ich
wie kriege ich sie perfekt hin dann habe
ich den burgerring in der Schublade
gesehen und habe mir gedacht hey cool
ich mache morgen ein nachgemacht Ikea
zimschnecken im burgerring damit s per
perekt rund werden wie viele werde ich
jetzt daraus zubereiten ich würde sagen
ich ma mal so 12 Z Schnecken okay also
die Rolle einfach schön hinlegen und wie
gesagt schneide ich das jetzt mit dem
Faden weil ich dann von außen nach innen
sozusagen Schneide und nicht mit einem
Messer durch dann werden sie flach das
nicht so schön und jetzt geht ihr hier
mit dem Faden nämlich einmal rein und
oben verzwirbeln und
durchschneiden
ich bin ja kein Perfektionist aber ich
will schon dass die Schnecken jetzt
perfekt werden ihr könnt jetzt so auf
ein Blech setzen mit etwas Abstand denn
die werden schon noch ordentlich groß
und könnt sie dann einfach backen aber
ich möchte dass sie die perfekte runde
Form bekommen deswegen nehme ich einfach
diese kleinen süßen Backförmchen die
nehme ich ja oft für Burgerbrötchen aber
ihr seht ihr könnt ihr auch zum Süßen
Backen verwenden ich tue s jetzt nur ein
bisschen mit backtrinpray einfetten
setzt die da rein ich tu auch ein paar
separat Backen dass ihr einfach mal so
den Unterschied
seht ich bestreich sie jetzt noch ein
bisschen mit flüssiger Butter und dann
kommt Hagelzucker drauf dann sind sie
erst richtig original ich bin mal
gespannt wie der Unterschied wird so mit
und ohne Ring
außenrum und wie sie allgemein
werden ihr seht schon die sehen schon
richtig fluffig aus hier in der Küche
ist es auch sehr warm das heißt die
gehen jetzt gerade noch gut auf aber ich
Deck sie trotzdem noch mal ab lass sie
so 15 Minuten aufgehen und dann kommen
sie in den heißen Ofen oder ihr schiebt
sie jetzt einfach in den kalten Ofen und
dann kann mit der Aufheizzeit sozusagen
der Teig auch noch mal aufgehen aber da
ich gerade frisch die anderen gebacken
habe ist der Ofen schon heiß und ich
musste hier ein bisschen aufgehen
[Musik]
lassen
jetzt sind die Zimtschnecken fertig ich
muss sagen oh mein Gott sie sind noch
schöner als ich es mir ausgemalt habe
ich muss sagen die in den burgerring
haben diese perfekte runde Form die
anderen sind halt schön groß geworden W
mal sehen ich ich würde mal sagen vom
Geschmack her sind die im burgerring
natürlich saftiger weil sie kompakter
sind in die Höhe wachsen dadurch
fluffiger werden und die hier die auf
dem Blech gebacken sind sind trotzdem
gut aber die haben halt mehr Fläche
können eher Austrocknen als jetzt die
hier ich würde jetzt aber sagen ich bin
nicht die Person die wirklich jetzt hier
diese Hefeschnecken beurteilen kann denn
wir haben ja einen
hefeschneckenpzialisten bei uns im Team
Tolga bitte einmal
reinmarschieren herzlich willkommen
schön dass du da bist und uns mit deiner
Expertise zur Seite stehst mhm tolg was
machen denn für dich die perfekten
besten Schnecken aus also das
allerwichtigste ist es muss in der Küche
riechen und es riecht im ganzen Welly
hier okay ist noch nicht Weihnachten
aber Weihnachtsstimmung ist langsam
kommt z Weihnachten m ich liebe
Schnecken das weißt Du ich weiß deswegen
habe ich ja auch extra dich einbestellt
was macht eine gute Schnecke noch aus
sie muss auf jeden Fall rund sein sie
darf nicht zu trocken sein
und die muss einfach m so fluffy
sein auf eine Wolke beißen so irgendwie
so außen darf schon bisschen härter sein
aber
so okay und man muss die so auseinander
reißen können okay wow optisch ist es
natürlich schwer zu sagen welche ich
gemacht habe und welche die von Ikea
sind
h ach so
ja das sieht man ah die sind aber auch
muss man sagen geschmacklich gut s eine
probieren kommen wir
probieren teilen so eigentlich Teil ich
keine schmecken weil also du hast
ja ich mag's
halt ich rede nicht mal mit vollem Mund
i'm sorry
ich mag's halt dass das in der Mitte das
ist
so so sagt mir das Wort so leicht
Magic ich lieb das das muss eine
Schnecke haben jetzt bin ich gespannt
auf die okay die seh oh mein Gott guck
dir das mal
an no way
warte guck das kanst so einfach so ja
wie so ein Hütchenspieler ich glaub sind
die besten Schnecken
oh mein Gott ja oh mein Gott oh
wow hat aber überlegt mus sagen was mir
jetzt hier nur fehlt aber jetzt nur
optisch dass diese Masse aber ich frage
mich was in der Masse drin ist weil bei
denen geht es nicht in Hefeteig rein und
ich glaube bei uns ist einfach das
volle bestimmt ist da ganz viel Chemie
einfach drin oder
irgendwas
du weißt ja bei einem Video schon
geweint gehabt ich weine jetzt nicht
noch mal okay eigentlich mag ich dir ja
wenn die richtig warm
sind
gut so gut okay okay gut so wei ich will
gerade
SPR aber die sind richtig
lecker oh
meint
okay ich will jetzt bisschen Hel
abkriegen aber sag mir mal was das hier
ist wie
Hagelzucker schmeckt so geil haelzucker
ist so eine
Zutat die man früher oft benutzt hat so
bei Hefegebäck da streut man das oben
drauf ich muss aber auch sagen dass ich
Hagelzucker bestimmt seit 13 Jahren
nicht mehr bei mir zu Hause hatte weil
ich halt Hefegebäck generell entweder
mit einem Zuckerguss oder mit irgendwas
gemacht habe und dieses typische
Hefegebäck mit Hagelzucker nicht
zubereitet habe aber so darin und in
belgischen Waffeln ist auch Hagelzucker
drin dieses wenn du reinbeißt dieser
Crunch ah das ist Hagelzucker da müssen
wir Belgische Waffeln machen okay dann
machen wir belgische Waffel ich glaube
ich brauche dich jetzt nicht zu fragen
wie sie schmecken die sind bombastisch
geworden sind die schon fotografiert
neer müssen uns kurz gedulden aber ich
habe da noch zwei die kann nehmen und
dann fotografieren wir die das Rezept
findet ihr wie immer auf sellis-blog.de
oder in meiner App und falls ihr solche
Rezepte und dieses Video nicht verpassen
wollt gerne den Kanal abonnieren und
Glocke aktivieren denn je
mehr Accounts ihr folgt umso weniger
seht ihr von mir das ist leider so denn
immer mehr creater auf der Welt immer
mehr Dinge die man toll findet und schön
findet ich kenn es ja auch von mir ich
folg so viel Menschen und wenn man nicht
bewusst dran denkt oh die ich muss mal
auf den Kanal gehen und muss mal gucken
kamusade was neues gemacht dann würde
ich das nicht sehen so viele Menschen
halt was neues machen ich se z.B das von
Dir auch nicht immer ja und ob ich
abonnit hab aber ich habe mir den Haken
reingemacht damit ich direkt benachung
nämlich muss man dran denken sturmi hat
ein neues Video gemacht ich guck mal was
der macht ich guck mal was die macht
deswegen immer schön reinschauen bist
zum nächsten Mal tschüss ich darf schon
ein paar mitnehmen oder ich habe noch
paar
Nachbarn noch der Tipp wegen dem
Einfrieren ja kann man die einfrieren ja
also wenn Schnecken geschnitten habt
einfach auf dem auf einem Blech am
besten kurz vorfrieren bis sie bisschen
geforen sind und dann könnte es auch in
der töte einpacken und dann lagern und
dann kannst immer wenn du eine Schnecke
Backen willst zack aufs Blech in Ofen
backen aber ich meine wer backt schon
eine Schnecke du machst immer das ganze
Rezept ganze Rezept ja dann kann ich
aber jeden Tag eine Schnecke Essen so
h super Tipp B zum nächsten Mal und
falls ihr noch ein Original habt was ich
für euch nachmachen soll schreibt mir
gerne jetzt in die Kommentare ich nimm
das ter bleibt mit den Schnecken da die
müssen ins fotobüro ja oh
[Musik]
Mann